[Musica]
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
vari j oggi ragazzi siamo il video
ufficiale ho ricevuto questa lettera
incredibile da mattel
ciao vj le lunghe e desideranti partite
ad uno si avvicinano abbiamo deciso di
donarci una piccola carta da giocare per
distrarre i tuoi avversari
buona fortuna il team be1 italia nn
abbiamo uno che il gioco base dopo uno
ovviamente abbiamo dos perché
giustamente giù anche dos 1 h2o to go
accaduto sarebbe uno idrorepellente ci
puoi giocare in piscina cellulari in
bagno e abbiamo la chicca della giornata
ragazzi 1 flip la versione di uno un po
particolare che esso vi vado a spiegare
ma la giochiamo con degli amici
non potevo avere amici normali o no però
ma restiamo solo in tre e non è mancata
che manca
quarto è anche lui ematiche lavoro
chiariti e certamente bellissimo parlato
lo vedi che c'è un tv di chi si vede che
non ti si vede facciamo i seri per una
volta facciamo i sei giochiamo ragazzi
guardate dove vi ho portato oggi siete
pronti per fare questo incredibile gioco
perché non è come una normale questo
numero un po strano non è uno ma è uno
flip ok bisogna flippare le card la
carta flip che ti gira completamente il
mazzo la data materie che fa il mazzo
nero e c'è il mazzo bianco vale jacopo
un campione di uno tra i vincenti sto
spiegando per pietro cioè parlato sia di
casa una cosa rara
giochiamo con le regole di uno l'unica
regola che non terrei è che chi vince
vince cioè quando hai fatto ora e non
teniamo contro il mondo c'è e va bene
adesso le carte
facciamo che le dava in senso orario fa
caldo è perché le ragioni o tentativo di
crea protettiva anche due anni sguardi
poi la mamma mi sgrida le 11 4 nella
mente un po h m cioè che in faccia a
faccia non lavoro no no no non ne parla
di donne
la prima carta o un bel 7
si parte guarda che ho già messo giù il
9 ora si colore giallo incredibile
se avete una cosa mai un cambierò
fulmini faccio questa pioggia abbiamo le
carte creature che la cosa mi tocca
no io ho fatto la flic no io ho fatto lo
ha ferito è fatto la foto scritto io beh
la zia e anche quello è qui almeno i
colori non le tabelline ragazzi ho
arricchito un 5 volare e non cinque
carte nor ore a giocare è bello avere o
la collezione in mano la vede che c'è a
me il mare mi piace proprio tanto a me
mi sopra funzioniamo si cambiano
mamma mia che caldo colpiscimi estate
colpisce anche ecco vita per manolo
santana rimandano indietro
bravissimo e tocca però in tutto questo
gli autobot lo contesti dai venti
solisti che la coscienza che si parla si
sa lui mi fa ridere non a noi
in più un urlo anche in altre carte ma
guarda che va che passano con le due
pesca due cartevalori tantissimo che
dovrebbero di scegliere chi edile blu
ragazzi freddo ragazzi è una freddo
guarda come mi riordino i capelli in una
botta sola sai benissimo è il resto di
pagare abbiamo detto vai vai
guarda le carte
prima perde la ragione per cui tarantino
effettivamente ragione ai ragazzi sta
poco 185 sono 85 pagava arancione e mi
volete prendere in giro anche secondo me
perché non soffre sconveniente di
diritto malato per quasi in una protesta
se cambiassimo ancora un po basta ti
prego bardhaj ci porti sono la luna caso
addirittura la regale ragazzi se
guardato bene i miei scritti perché non
puoi cos'è sta roba
si poteva fare perché lo chiediamo
allora può controbattere più noto salti
il turno rate regia prego e lo farò
subito sai così le due carte perfetto
proprio è come si suol dire voli vincere
telefonica se vuole il calore ok ma sa
che i giornali di buttare giù le case 10
mio sento odore di vittoria doretti
continuità ai loro
sento odore di vittoria posso chiedere i
porti in un posto nuovo per la vittoria
di roma
guardate qua non guardare giorno vado a
giocare non rischia guardate giu ragazzi
io la sentirei non va lei e le ha detto
io sono male è vero che scoprivano
aspetta a carte rossi può bella davanti
ci sono rituali ragazzi riprese 444 e
altri un piccione tanto va bene allora
che vincoli di giorno che porta fuori
bordone del tunnel e forti fortunale che
la forza che posso che fare ragazzi
secondo me buttarti giù dal grattacielo
perché ti vogliamo troppo bene lorenzo
era quante cabine vogliamo troppo
volerei se faccio così volo usiamo come
gemma ipad restino e mia mamma non
guardare la chiave è venuto benissimo
tra l'altro ma mai rimane così che sei
un fan sanno personale verderame tocca
si ricordi la faida e poi invertito
amico mio e di fare fallo
guarda che se tutti ma nessuno si sa che
le dico anche 16 pesca mille carte è
stata né dubbio
io ho capito che strana ma vv.uu 5
perché adesso 11 10 ricordati che lui
non ha il verde quindi si canta
paparazzi si clima di nuovo girate tutto
a mare pare valle l'hostess upi
aggiornati signora forte post forte su
una donna possa vede una golf massa ne
passa ma possiamo anche andare a giocare
al lavoro soltanto io mai un video
girato a sky ha vinto pietro ha vinto
pietro a bisogna che pietro scelga la a
chi far fare la penitenza che hanno
scelto i ragazzi perché abbiamo fatto
una storia dove abbiamo dei ragazzi che
penitenza volete per il finale abbiamo
scelto la ceretta è tra l'altro voi
avete scelto ceretta purtroppo
ovviamente quindi pietro chi deve fare
la ceretta che ha meno peli sulle
braccia no ma chi l'ha donata maledetta
sulla mano
calano la barca almeno mi vuoi lasciare
quelli sulle braccia ma ci sono anche le
cerette magiche che si tirano da sole
allora sulle maniche forza questa roba
non voglio non voglio sentire facciamo
in fretta facciamo in fretta ricorda
serate in fretta calma perché lui si
stop
bye bye bye bayou the dude le braccia
sul tavolo che almeno lo sta meglio
tutte e due le brava sul tavolo ma e
mezzo di fare in mezzo ma no di qua ma
no di qua si no ma come entra ma il male
ma non era sola legato a grassi una sola
si vede dalla faccia che voglia 3
aspettano che male ma malissimo fa male
fa male fa male voglio andare a casa
nascerebbe un fattore estetico e jacopo
che va bene va bene adesso bisogna farsi
col braccio però schips i ragazzi vi
ringrazio per aver partecipato al video
al piacere lega lo stesso turno
volevo dirvi che quest'anno al milan
gainesville 2019 si terrà la prima 1
national cup
siccome io sono bravo 1 sfiderò il
campione della national lauro national
cup e vi farò sapere camion in antichi
vi farò sapere lei
vi farò sapere le imposte grazie niente
per illegalità meli dauni che sono gli
utenti ricche alla prossima
[Musica]